the dog strapped to his back is an
individual touch but this man's choice
of two wheels is what several European
governments are hoping as many of us as
possible use for lockdown travel his
Rome notorious for its alarming traffic
not previously a bike friendly City but
150 kilometers of emergency cycle lanes
are being created as an alternative to
public transport better late than never
says this spokeswoman nice yeah McCune
think DC me we are very happy we've been
asking them for years many of us not
only me I'm only the president of the
save the cyclists Association many have
fought to achieve this the corona virus
pandemic has prompted an urgent rethink
of how people get about Madrid has bans
cars from 29 streets this weekend to
accommodate those taking their rationed
outdoor exercise on bike and foot a
torch a train station like many
transport hubs in Europe is mostly empty
lockdowns and stay at home orders have
kept people off the continents trains
trams and buses but lifting restrictions
without risking fresh outbreaks poses
many difficult questions physical
distancing is all but impossible on many
of the continents overcrowded mass
transit systems so how do you get the
economy's cogs moving again if people
can't get back to work safely
the British government also thinks
cycling and walking are a big part of
the answer it's announced two and a half
billion dollars in funding even with
public transport reverting to a full
service once you take into account the
two metered social distancing rule there
would only be effective capacity for one
in ten passengers in many parts of our
network just a tenth of the old capacity
since the epidemic began the UK has seen
a big increase in cycling anyway it
wants to harness this fresh enthusiasm
to help pedal power it out of the
coronavirus crisis war ii challenge al
jazeera